In this video, we'll look at how to set up your firewall and
configure port forwarding to ensure that OSC works as expected.
To start, let's look into our Windows Defender firewall settings.
You will be able to find it in settings,
and I'm also going to try to do it on my computer as well.
First, I will go to settings,
and it's already looking different because I'm now at Windows 11.
Let me try to go to Windows Firewall.
Windows Defender Firewall is the one we want to look into,
so now let's go to here,
and let's check two places.
First, let's go to advanced settings here,
and the place we want to see is the inbound and outbound rules.
So for the inbound rules,
I'm not going to specify any application,
I'm just going to create a new one,
new rule here, and I want to specify a port.
I want to make sure the port is not blocked on this computer.
So let's say I want to use,
and another reminder is that OSC usually
is going through UDP because it's a real-time protocol.
So usually we will specify UDP,
but there's no harm to also add one more rule for TCP.
The port we're going to use today,
and we're going to say it's just for example,
I'm going to say it's 22222,
the same as on the screenshot on the slide,
and we want to use allow the connection.
Next, and we will apply it to a domain and private and public.
Next, and we'll give it a name,
but because I already have this inbound and outbound rule set,
I'm not going to finish the final part,
but you can just name it something like 22222 for OSC,
inbound, something like that.
You can hit Finish to add the rule,
and same thing goes to album rules.
You can create a new rule,
specify if you just want it to be open on a specific program,
we can do it like this,
and then we will specify the program,
but in our use case,
I'm going to specify the port.
I want it for UDP,
and I'll do it again for 22222,
because I'm going to send message out from 22222 as well.
Next, and I'll do allow the connection.
Next, allow it on all three domains,
and finally, I'll give it a name and finish it.
Noting that if you're in a traditional local area network setup,
you likely won't actually need to open the ports that you're using,
but almost certainly you will if you're
going across subnets or over the Internet.
Now we make sure that this computer is not
blocking the connection at our port 22222.
Now we want to make sure when a message comes into the network,
that message coming from 22222 is being forwarded
to this computer that we just configured.
Let's go to our default gateway.
The way to find our default gateway will be,
let's press the Windows button,
and let's type CMD for command prompt.
Now we open this command prompt,
let's type in ipconfig.
Now we have all these IPs here,
and the one we want to look for is the default gateway.
For me, it will be 192.168.1.1.
Also a reminder that if you're looking for your local IP,
it will be the IPv4 address here.
For me, 192.168.1.245.
So if you want to do
a LAN communication with other device under the same network,
this is the IP that represents my current computer.
So I'm going to use my default gateway IP,
and we will move on to the next part,
to go to our router and set the port forwarding rules.
Now let's move on to create
a new port forwarding rule on the router.
So this part is going to look very
different from provider to provider,
and for me, I'm using Optimum.
So for Optimum users,
this is the page you're going to see.
First, we need to type in our Optimum ID and
password to login and start creating new rules.
For different users, you might open into a router setting page,
you might need to put in passwords,
it might be on your router.
So please check your router and
your Internet provider for how to access this setting page.
So for all the Optimum users,
let's look at my page for example.
So here, I already logged into my Optimum account.
I can see that I have
one wired device and I have no Wi-Fi device,
which is probably not true.
So a reminder for Optimum users,
you can always hit this refresh
to get a new list of results here.
A lot of time, it's not very sensitive.
We have to refresh multiple times to have the correct result.
But I'm only going to deal with the wired one here,
so I'm going to leave it as is.
We will scroll down to the port forwarding part,
and I will hit Manage.
So here, we can see that I already have several rules here,
and including the rule 2222 here,
I'm just going to delete it and I will do it again.
So we deleted the port,
and now we can use
Add Port Forwarding Rule to create a new one.
The process is very straightforward.
Just select the device you want to use.
Usually, it will show you the name of your computer.
But if you don't see it,
you can also come back to our command prompt and make sure
the IPv4 address is matching the IPv4 address
here to make sure they are the same device.
I will collect my desktop,
and the port I want to use is 2222.
So now any messages coming from this port 2222 going
to this Internet is going to be forwarded to my desktop here.
The protocol is both TCP and UDP,
but we can also specify it to be just TCP or just UDP.
I'll leave it as is and save.
Now, it is creating a new port forwarding rule.
It might take a couple of seconds.
Just let it run.
After a couple of seconds,
you should see a green thing shows
that the port forwarding rule has successfully added.
Now, you can see this new rule called 2222 for TCP and UDP.
That's it.
If you're not using your ISP as a router
or otherwise don't have the ISP in control of your port forwarding,
you might want to do it through an individual router.
So I'll show you briefly here an example with a Netgear router.
So in this case, I go to router login.net,
which essentially takes me to
the gateway that June already specified before.
I can go over to advanced here and advanced setup.
Again, like June mentioned,
this will be different from router to router.
We're just trying to show a couple of examples here.
But if I go down to port forwarding,
port triggering in this particular example,
very similar to what we just saw,
I can go ahead and add a new service.
I've got to drop down here to specify what exactly it's for,
or I can just type it in here as add custom service.
So I can say that I want to open up port 2222,
and I'll do the same thing for both internal and external,
or if I hit that checkbox,
it happens automatically, and I'll just call this OSC testing.
Then I just need to make sure that I am
specifying the correct internal IP address.
Now, it's not clear from here
which of these IP addresses is my device.
I happen to know that it's 0.3
because of using IP config and looking at the IPv4 address.
So I would then just click apply,
and now we have this new port forwarding rule
ready to go through my separate router.
Do note that sometimes you have to tell your ISP
to specifically disable the router configuration on it.
I actually was not able to use this port forwarding
correctly until my ISP specifically disabled
the router that was built into my modem.
In the next video,
we'll begin exploring the Unreal Engine sample project
that we've put together for this course.